how's it going everybody it's Warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU and we have a pretty exciting report
today we have a new report stating that
Marvel Studios is developing an
Illuminati project now this is big news
and the best news about this is that
it's not the first report I was given
the exclusive scoop six months ago in
January by Mikey Sutton to report that
Marvel Studios is in fact bringing the
Illuminati into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and this new report only backs
up the claim that Marvel is indeed
bringing the men so one of the coolest
groups from Marvel Comics the Illuminati
is going to be coming to the MCU and
we'll talk about what that means in this
video but first if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you stay up to date on
everything relating to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and so you can enter
this week's giveaway for a chance to win
a Hawkeye Funko pop all you got to do is
subscribe like the video and leave a
comment about the video down below so
this new and recent report comes from
the Illuminati calm the Illuminati has
leaked many different Marvel things
concerning the Marvel Cinematic Universe
lately and has been right about a lot of
them if not all of them and here's what
they have to say about the Illuminati
coming to the MCU they say that their
team has learned from a new cast listing
that Marvel Studios
is in the early stages of developing
some kind of project based off of Marvel
Comics is Illuminati team they report
that the only confirmed details that
they have right now is that Marvel's CCO
and Marvel Studios President Kevin Feige
is listed as the producer for this
project and the current title of the
project is Marvel's Illuminati there's
no other talent attached and there is no
confirmation on whether the project is a
movie or a feature show on Disney plus
they also go on to say that this listing
is incredibly early in the development
process and it seems that there are many
details that are up in the air at this
moment and this will most likely be a
project that we end up seen not in phase
4 but in phase 5 now this is great news
and there are a few reasons why one is
that the team is amazing it's an awesome
group which kind of leads us into number
two as well as the characters that it's
going to introduce to the MCU in the
comics the team is formed by Iron Man
and the team consists of dr. strange
namor the sub-mariner blackbolt the king
of the Inhumans Professor Xavier mr.
fantastic and of course Iron Man himself
so a lot of new characters that we've
been waiting for that are not in the MCU
yet should be coming relatively soon now
of course Iron Man is no longer with us
so he's not going to be the one to form
the Illuminati it's most likely going to
be Doctor Strange in my original report
from the exclusive from Mikey Sutton he
reported that he heard that the
Illuminati was going to be in dr.
strange in the multiverse of madness
possibly in the post-credits scene for
multiverse of madness now even though
that the Illuminati's report says that
the Illuminati are going to be getting
their own project that doesn't mean that
they won't appear in another movie or
show especially if it's just a teaser at
the end of multiverse of madness to set
up the Illuminati in the future Marvel
Studios of course does this all the time
and Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness was originally supposed to be
coming in May of 2021 now pretty much
the entire phase for Slade has been
pushed back at this point due to the
corona virus so multiverse of madness is
most likely to come a little bit later
however since the Illuminati project be
that a movie or a show is going to be
coming probably in phase 5 it would make
perfect sense for multiverse of madness
to set it up to come a couple of years
later this is what Marvel does all the
time so two reports that the Illuminati
are coming to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe one exclusive from Mikey Sutton
that you heard here first let me know
how excited you are to see this group
come to the MCU be sure to let me know
in the comments down below
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe to stay up-to-date on all
things relating to the marvel cinematic
universe if you like G fuel be sure to
use code cosmic and for live updates you
can follow me on Twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof